[Music]
welcome everybody to the data science
hangout i hope everyone's having a great
week
and hello special hello to anyone that's
joining for the first time too it's
great to meet you i'm rachel i'm the
host of the data science hangout
i'm calling in from boston
as well as asthma
i'm in our studio office today
this is an open space for the whole data
science community to connect and chat
about data science leadership questions
you're facing and
what's really just going on in the world
of data science
so if you ever want to go back and
re-watch past
sessions or share it with someone who's
missed
it is recorded and it will be shared to
our brand new data science hangout site
i don't know if anybody saw that it's
right on the rstudio page now
and i'll share it in the chat window
in just a bit if our team isn't on yet
but we really want this to be a space
where everybody can participate and we
can hear from everyone
so there's three ways to ask questions
you can jump in live and raise your hand
on zoom maybe the easiest way with a
bigger group
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and if you're like in a coffee shop or
your dogs are barking or you want me to
read it just put a little star
at the end of it
but we also have a slido link that we'll
share in the chat right now where you
can ask questions anonymously too
i just want to reiterate that we love to
hear from everyone no matter your level
of experience or area of work too
but with that i'm so happy to be joined
by my co-host for today asthma to me the
director of analytics at pursuit care
and asthma i'd love to just kind of turn
it over you to introduce yourself and
maybe some of the work that you do at
pursuit care too
um
thanks everyone for joining this
data science hangout i'm really excited
to
talk about the work that we do at pursue
care and how i fit in
there but also to learn from
from all of you so hope we have some fun
here
uh i'm asma i'm the director of
analytics and research at pursuit care
pursue care is a telehealth company
which specializes in treating mental
health disorders
uh specifically substance use disorder
uh we are a telehealth company first but
we do have also in-person
clinics
we've been in operation for three years
now
awesome and i i know you just kind of
you just started in this role
was it a few months ago i can't keep
track of time no
yeah i've been working at pursue care um
since
last year february last so i'm about to
to have my one-year anniversary
coming up
wow that goes by fast
um
so
while we're waiting for a few questions
to come in i'd love to hear a little bit
about how you're building up this team
yeah so i was the company's first uh
data person
uh so uh that came
with some challenges but also some
excitement because you know we we got to
kind of explore the best tech stack for
us
um and
you know we weren't i guess you know
behold into some legacy code or legacy
uh platforms
so uh with that you know we looked at
different vendors and and given that i
was an r
programmer um the
the decision there was was quite uh easy
in terms of picking sort of the
the publishing platform that we were
going to use our studio connect to no
one surprise there
and of course you know a data warehouse
that plays nicely with that and and so
forth
awesome so how many people are part of
the data team now
yeah so it's me and three data engineers
yeah
we're hopefully going to grow that um
you know not going into next year for
sure
that's something that comes up on this
call a lot is like the topic of hiring
data engineers versus data scientists
and which comes first and
that's interesting to hear you have so
you have three data engineers to start
yeah it's i think i i put out this tweet
i think a while ago but like all data
scientists want is a data engineer
honestly um
because we're a healthcare company and i
think the people that that work in
healthcare would sympathize with this
you know it's
it's it's complex to deliver the care
that we do and with with that complexity
comes with interfacing different vendors
so different data sources
so it's it's really important to invest
i think in data engineering such that
the reconciliation of that data across
the the many vendors
is insured
data quality is also super super
important
in any field but especially so in
healthcare
so i think it made a lot of sense for us
to invest in
in data engineers early on
so um have the rstudio team help me
monitor the chat for questions but if no
one asks anything yet
i'd love to ask you because i feel like
you do an awesome job at networking and
i always see
you on twitter as well and
would love to hear a little bit about
how
you network in this data science world
um
and if that helps with how that's helped
you with maybe getting into your role
now
or any advice you have for all of us
yeah i think my boss is on this zoom uh
nick mercadante he's the he's the ceo of
pursuit care and the way we've met is
through hockey twitter so
we both like hockey um we made a hobby
out of it out of analyzing uh hockey
data
and so the networking i guess there in
terms of getting my job was pretty
organic
and i and i think most of my sort of
networking efforts are
natural in a way you know i
i invest in my public presence for sure
you know in terms of like time spent on
on twitter
um
and i think you know over the years if
you're intentional about you know
interacting in a positive
uh way with with the people in your
community whether that's the your
professional community or
uh sports or any interests um then you
know it just i think it makes it that
that much easier to to build that
connection build that rapport and you
know when you're looking for your next
step then um the awkwardness and and all
of that kind of dissipates
definitely
and i hope people are able to do that
here in this environment too
i see zach you asked a question in the
chat would you want to jump in
yes i
continue on the hockey thing i found
as esme is that how you pronounce it
sorry if i got it wrong oh it's okay
thank you
uh
found you via your big data box mission
last year uh one night actually really
enjoyed i believe it was a fine list as
well
uh
i was wondering what other competitions
you recommended because i've got
i'm new to this and i'm trying to look
at other competitions i've entered this
year to the big data though
i was wondering what other competitions
were around trying to beat my cv to stay
like stand out from the crowd
sure yeah the the nfl big data ball is
such a tremendous opportunity
to
you know
get exposed to
a very big and complex data set
um and there's a lot of eyes on that
competition
nfl staff other sports leagues have
hired from
people's submissions and and so on and i
think that
uh sports is a great
is a great field to kind of you know
practice your your data science skills
and and post it because
sports fans are very much hungry for
that for that kind of thing
um i think kaggle always has
competitions ongoing and
it's great because it spans many fields
that you may be exploring finance
healthcare even
so i highly recommend you know using
kaggle given that submissions are are
online you can you know it makes it very
easy to just import that code and tinker
with it yourself and learn a few things
along the way while also
building your your portfolio
thank you
craig i see you mentioned sliced in the
chat too do you want to ask that
question live
yeah sorry i don't have a camera i don't
know if that works you hear me or not
can hear you perfectly
thanks um i was just wondering if um
you've noticed the data science
community grow in streaming platforms
like twitch and youtube obviously drop
streams on youtube
every tuesday i believe i don't know if
he's still doing it honestly
but yeah have you heard of um
the sliced data scientists competition
and do you plan on um participating in
the future
yeah it's been super exciting um
following sliced over the summer i think
that was literally the hi one of the
highlights of my summer quite frankly
um i love just how
welcoming that environment was to to the
participants themselves even though it
was a quote
competition
i learned so much from observing those
participants do these timed challenges
and it's been really great this kind of
shift to video honestly it's it's it's a
little less i think for me personally a
little less tiring
to to watch
data science and and to learn
um
how
these
experts go about it live because you see
them you know sometimes debug
live or or change things on the fly and
it's it also helped a lot with i think
my own imposter syndrome
uh you know just seeing that you know
they they also get tripped up and they
also use the pipe instead of plus
whenever you know they're using ggplot2
that kind of thing so
yeah definitely have noticed a big
a bigger shift in into video and it's
it's very much a welcome one at least
for me
definitely i see a few people commenting
about that in the chat too i know julia
silgi from our studio does that quite a
bit
i see there's an anonymous question that
came through a great question that's
what are some pitfalls that you would
give advice on to avoid for the first
data analysts in a company with no data
pipeline
that wants to make data-driven decisions
yeah i think
trying to do too much
um is
is is a bad
play
um
i think also making sure that you have a
lot of face time with
with the stakeholders is is important um
i think you know i had sort of many
ideas of what i wanted to to do
to do with this data but when you
actually sit down with the people that
will be using this data
um
it looked it looked differently so i
think just making sure you have that
face time
that you do your due diligence in terms
of you know what what your tech stock is
going to look like
uh make sure you
uh
right from the get go have
reproducibility and code quality
in mind as you're building out those
those pipelines um
are all important considerations i think
definitely thank you
jeffrey i i see you had a question that
i'd love to pass over to you to ask live
and i figured i say this too if people
want to introduce yourselves i know it's
been a long time since we
did that and there's quite a few people
on now so when you ask the question feel
free to
introduce yourselves to
yeah sure are you all labor able to hear
me
yep sounds good
i'm jeffrey sumner i'm a data engineer
at a
gas pipeline company
my question was around as you build out
your team do you plan to
be focused more as a centralized data
science team or more of a decentralized
team within your organization and if
anyone else had any kind of comments on
that as well i was asked that question
yesterday and
i really thought it depends more on
maybe the culture of the company on on
how you handle that problem but just
curious on
what others think
uh thank you jeffrey if i if i may ask
what what is the difference between a
centralized team on a decent line
my definition of it at least is
centralized would be you have more of a
data science team reporting up to a data
science manager whereas decentralized
would be more along the lines of you've
got a team within sales a team within
marketing or a data science member on
the marketing team the sales team
uh finance whatever it may be
yeah that's that's such an interesting
question um
not sure if i'm best equipped to answer
it i think i'll just draw from
from pursuit care uh we have you know of
course you know typical departments you
know marketing finance
ops
and i think it would make sense one day
to have
decentralized teams so such that those
data scientists can become
subject matter experts as much as they
could
in those specific fields such as finance
or marketing
i i think right right now it makes more
sense to have a centralized team given
given our size were about 70 employees
strong
um and we're really at the phase of just
understanding this data and and trying
to better understand our business our
patients um but i think as you know as
we we become a more mature company
our questions will probably become more
complex in nature and and so having
those decentralized teams in which they
can once again have more face time
with the subject matter experts would
would make sense i think but interested
in in other people's perspectives here
probably i see you had your hand raised
do you have feedback to add on this this
topic or another question
no
on this topic um i fully agree with what
asthma is saying here
i think it is
the
it can be a little bit of organizational
structure there is no right answer here
both are valid
but for a company that is starting out a
data science team
um i think a centralized setup is good
because they can then
develop
and say grow this
data science function as to how it will
work in this company
set some good practices etc and when
you're building a team new hires have a
place to come and learn say company
processes how does data science work who
are the best and so forth however as
this function grows
having data science teams within the
marketing within hr within finance etc
etc shows a level of maturity now that
these functions can
exist and thrive within those functions
um you know within these
non-iit non-data science organization
and continue to add value so i think
there is no right answer but i think
if you look at the growth of the data
science function within an organization
um i fully agree with what asthma says
start centrally but as you grow
scientists need to understand the
language of the finance team language of
the operations team etc and for them to
be part of that organization accelerates
that
growth
thank you prabha i i see a new buddy
that you have your hand raised as well
if you want to jump in on on the topic
yeah thanks rachel i was actually going
to say everything that prabhakar said
that when you're starting out and this
is something that we are currently
struggling or working on within our
company
that
we are a fairly new small
four or five people um
data science team within one project so
we are trying to hire more people keep
it more centralized but at the same time
we've recently
um put out a posting for
a job in a different team because we
also want to
expand our work beyond our team because
our teams are segregated based on the
line of work rather than just
departments so we work on public health
but we want to do a lot more data
science work in economic growth or
climate change so
we've convinced at least our economic
growth team to hire one data scientist
and
the way i think initial early on having
it centralized is also very important
because there is no mentorship or
guidance available from those other
teams so that's extremely important like
prabhakar said to develop
good practices and
[Music]
you know just organization by practices
but we are
also trying to uh even with
decentralized if we convince more teams
to hire data scientists to keep it more
this bits if it's centralized by
organizing a technical working group
around it where we meet and try to
standardize practices or release
standard
training modules
thank you i think there is there is a
happy middle right once you once there
you you know an organization has
achieved this a decentralized model um
in in my company
you know the
the finance organization is set up in a
centralized decentralized
it exists in both ways me and i work in
the supply chain department of my
company
we have a finance lead for the supply
chain organization
but that person in if you look at his
reporting structure he reports into the
finance organization so he brings that
finance expertise to the supply chain
organization but his manager he rolls up
into the cfo organization right so he
continues to have um
like
input from both places he knows about
supply chain but he also follows all the
best practices of finance within within
my company so there is a
you know if if
a data science team has grown in
maturity to have
enough people
to
live and do data science for finance and
hr etc you don't have to cut off the
connection to the centralized data
science team that can still
exist definitely
jill i see you just asked a great
question right now in the
chat as well is it okay if i pass the
mic over to you nasa is that asthma
yeah of course
or i can start reading it jill but feel
free to jump into if you want to add any
other context but it's
is it okay to say that we are data
analysts and data scientists
interchangeably or are there specific
differences
i think
jacqueline and emily robinson's book on
data science
careers
has a really good definition
for for both and the subtle differences
between the both
of them
um
i think and this is gonna be wrong
because i don't recall those definitions
but i i think maybe data scientist
involves just a little bit more
you know engineering work ml ops devops
sort of work
um
but
honestly i use them interchangeably
but others might have
differing thoughts on on that
yeah
i feel like a lot of us do use them
interchangeably i know in past
conversations too we've talked a bit
about um
[Music]
like data analysts more so reporting on
the data
i don't know if anyone has other
thoughts you want to add there
feel free to raise your hands too if you
want to like i know it's hard with 100
people to just jump in so
falaq did you want to add anything
yes uh i
recently
attended some lectures about aiml
and in those lectures
[Music]
it was explained in a very
good way
the difference between data scientists
and data engineers
basically data scientists
are those people who understand the
um distribution about the data
and they figure out
based on the distribution what
class of
aml algorithms would be suitable
to handle that particular problem
so this is mostly done by data
scientists because there are multiple
[Music]
classes of aml algorithms that you can
use to solve your problem
but
and that
that thing and that work is done by data
center is to help you based on by
understanding your data by looking into
the data about the distribution of the
data you can figure out um what what
class of algorithm is best suited to
solve your specific problem
and once that is decided then the
data engineers or ml engineers they they
then solve the optimization problem so
within that specific class of algorithms
they figure out which
uh
specific algorithm with specific uh
with specific configurations this
algorithm which algorithm is going to
perform the best for that specific set
of data
thank you
i see there's so many great comments
coming in on the chat too and different
thoughts that people have on this
um
javier i see your hands raised do you
want to jump in
hey rachel i think the gentleman that
just spoke
kind of
you know articulated what i was
intending to say as well but i i would
say that's more from like a theoretical
data scientist standpoint
i mean some of the best
data scientists or you know our
programmers or python programmers that i
know
have the title of you know financial
modeler or
you know senior actuary
um some of the best programmers and like
package developers i know have the title
data analyst so
i think it really just depends on the
organization
like we have these guidelines that
you know are more like
an ideological function of a data
scientist versus a data analyst but i
really think in practice it's all over
the place
definitely
and yeah it definitely varies by the the
company and i see people are saying
mary's based on the location
as well
yeah um
i think morris
brought
a good question
to the table
data science versus business
intelligence
yeah so for me personally i use data
analysts and data scientists
interchangeably but i think there is
probably a meaningful difference there
between
a business analyst and
a data scientist
thank you all for
this discussion too
there's a lot of
not to crack up at some of these
i see a lot of other anonymous questions
coming in through on on slido
um
and one was
um going back to talking about live
debugging
someone said i had an interview recently
and they wanted me to solve write code
live i've always had issues when people
watch me working it makes me
uncomfortable
even if i know how to solve the problem
do you have any tips on how to get
better at that
um
first off i'm sorry you you had to do
that um
i really don't like that sort of live
interview
structure um
even less so if you need to debug
something live i know that sometimes i'm
on
zoom meetings where i'm displaying like
a data set or graph and sometimes have
to like code things on the fly because
someone asked a question and like i make
tons of mistakes tons of typos in front
of everyone that's just like the nature
of it
um in terms of getting better at that
um you know if if if that's going to be
sort of the standard for some companies
to still have those live
coding interviews maybe
streaming might be it might be a good
avenue to do that um you know you could
put up a stream and just have your
buddies join sort of a low pressure
way uh to do that um
would i do it to get better at live
coding interviews no because i just
wouldn't attend those
but
um streaming is tons of fun and i think
tan can can speak to that i really enjoy
his his streams and learn a lot in a
low stakes low pressure way
tan do you have any tips to share with
us then you want to put him in the spot
no worries you can put it in the chat
too
i'm sure everyone has their stories but
i've interviewed people who bombed
technical interview back when i thought
that they were a good idea i've hired
them anyway and they are awesome
great employees great team members great
across the board so
and just while we see frank on video i
feel like we ought to say
congratulations on your awesome marathon
time as well
uh i just saw that on linkedin
but uh sup i see you had your hand
raised too yeah i was just gonna kind of
add something that i've learned that was
some that was a bit interesting is that
sometimes the
uh the way to kind of i i i don't like
live live coding interviews whatsoever
but uh if you were to
participate in one sometimes it's not
about the right answer or being able to
like
you know find the bug or whatever it is
sometimes it's just a matter of like
seeing how someone reasons through doing
it or how they approach the problem uh
it's similar to kind of like those
really random consulting interview
questions that you might get like how
many jelly beans can you fit into an
airplane or something like there's no
real right answer but it's just a matter
of how you reason that so
um you know
you know there could be some utility
there and so i think that there may be
value if you can kind of change your
perspective
on what what it is they're trying to do
and maybe helps calm you in that
particular moment that there's not
necessarily a right answer sometimes
it's just a matter of how you work in
that kind of
uncomfortable
high pressure whatever situation so um
not endorsing them but you know some
something that you might be able to kind
of mental jiu-jitsu to help you make
yourself a little more comfortable
thank you that's a great point
i i hear somebody was just about to jump
in
prabha here
we do live coding interviewing for
recruiting into our team
um and i agree with what says right we
are
they
even if they're not able to do execute
or write code that
runs flawlessly
um that you know there are
i would
in those coding in the interview session
we evaluate them on seven or eight
different categories
writing code is one of those categories
um
so um just like how sub said it it is
their way of thinking
um do they and
one of the evaluation criteria is
when we give them a task let's say do
some exploratory data analysis with the
data set do they ask do they engage us
we are encouraging them to engage the
interviewing team
and ask the kind of questions that they
would try to get to the answer that we
are asking so that level of engagement
are they asking the right questions
coding is one out of
um say seven or eight different criteria
we're evaluating in that interview
session um
but now i you know based on all the
feedback and the sort of resistance i'm
seeing to live coding i i'll ask some of
our team members who've gone through
this live coding recruitment who's who
are part of the team i'm gonna go back
and ask them how did they feel doing the
live coding session um
i you know it's an interesting topic
and thanks for the comments yeah
that's a good idea to go back and go
back to them and ask them about it
i um oh sorry go ahead
oh um i i just remember an interview
that i that i very much enjoyed in which
i was given a take-home challenge and
then was brought back for a live
interview with the team to discuss my
approach in depth in which they also had
the opportunity to ask questions about
my approach and also give constructive
feedback about said approach um and i
think also it's a good way to sort of
gauge you know emotional intelligence
how do you take that feedback
and test for the for the soft skills so
i think that's i think that's a that's a
much happier medium that i think makes
as many people comfortable given that
you know people do struggle with with
live timed challenges
definitely and
i think this question kind of ties in to
this discussion as well but i see hugh
you asked any advice on dealing with
imposter syndrome
yeah i'd love to
hear
i'm hugh welch i'm a management analyst
with vha
you mentioned imposter syndrome earlier
and that's something i'm always
interested in hearing about
how people have
dealt with that many strategies that
they've developed
yeah
um
i think imposter syndrome is is kind of
just uh
part of the part of the deal here in in
our fields
uh but
i think you know surrounding yourself
with
humble
capable
friends whether that's through twitter
or slack communities
in which there is that honest
sort of
rapport in which you know you share
your wins and successes but you also
share your struggles and and there's an
environment in which you feel
comfortable asking even the smallest of
questions or so you perceive
i think goes goes a long way into
uh dampening that uh imposter syndrome
and community such as this one like
we're here you know sharing our
struggles and
and and so on um
so i think yeah i think in investing in
sort of a a group of friends in a
professional capacity
uh goes goes a long way in in terms of
helping that
awesome thank you
yeah
i i love talking about it in this type
of format as well because you realize
like how many people
do have imposter syndrome and what has
also been a little eye opening to me is
a bunch of data science leaders as well
that are on here who will like message
me after the fact and
and say something about imposter
syndrome too so i think it's good to
recognize that
a lot of us are feeling that
that's the thing that always surprises
me the most uh when you talk to somebody
who doesn't have a name for what they're
feeling you know like the idea that
somebody's going to come along and say
you don't belong here like i feel that i
thought it was only me like nope that's
everybody
good luck
tan i i see you have your hand raised
yeah i was asked for some thoughts on
streaming and uh live coding at one
point a little bit here um
personally i think that live coding
interviews
get a bad rep
um
in that i want to see
how people think and i try to stream the
same way where
i don't present myself as an expert
even though i consider myself a good art
coder i work through projects on stream
and i share how i think and i share
messing up and i think
being comfortable with that is useful um
i think my problem with take homes i'll
counter the um
kind of the
massive support for take homes is that i
feel like often it ends up being that
people spend so much time doing them
like it's for me personally i resp i
would rather
sit and this is coming from a perfectly
biased background because i am a
streamer and i'm very comfortable
sharing
um but
at the same time i would rather respect
someone's time and give them the option
to do a live coding interview because
really what i'm interested in isn't can
you deliver a perfect model at the end
of the interview or solve this cleaning
or whatever i want to see
the process and i want to see what it's
like to work with you as you talk
through stuff and what you think and so
when you do
take homes
if i give you a week deadline and i say
spend 24 hours on it you're still going
to spend all week all like nights on
this thing trying to get this job i
don't
love that
and if you can build up fluency and
confidence even in just pair programming
environments i think that that means so
much that you know
it matters that you can share your
process
and
that even the best of us eric is a great
hardcoder and you know we'll all
struggle on stream
and
feel safe doing so and there's there's a
huge part about psychological
safety there and building up your own
safety and build up your own comfort and
even if it's just pair programming
finding a friend finding a community
that will help you do that i think that
matters a ton
streaming definitely my preferred way to
do that but there's definitely um more
than one way to skin that cat
thank you so much tan
that's really really helpful
i um i see there's quite a few answers
on this topic too i'm trying to go in
order i see mike you have your hand
raised if you want to jump in
yeah thanks i mean i i suffer from
imposter syndrome i think it's
inevitable and it goes with the
territory i think because
we become
specialists in a very narrow field right
and the more specialist you become the
narrower the field it gets and then
eventually you hear someone who you
think is in a similar field to talk
about things that you think you don't
understand
and that pulls the rug out from under
you and and you know you're bound to
feel that oh my goodness i i don't know
anything
right so
i
i think it's especially tough if you're
trying to lead something
right because then you have people
working it for you under
in your team who are the ones who are
pulling the rug from under you right
so um i think
you've got to try and you know develop a
little bit of a thick skin
but also know what you know know what
you don't know and just be able to say
look i'm sorry i don't understand what
you're telling me um you know help me
out here help me learn
definitely thank you for sharing that
mike
um i know there's a ton of other
questions too that i want to make sure
that
we get to as well but i'd love to hear
the thoughts on this and anybody i see
you had your hand raised too
i'm gonna jump in
yeah i'm also gonna add on to this uh
hot topic of life coding
i my personal preferences always take
home
um and one of the things that
when we send out take home exercises or
when i do them myself we
try to
focus on asking
candidates to
comment their code really well so make
sure that
we are able to see their thinking
process and that's something i also try
to practice that i
comment on the code why i'm doing xyz
and
uh you know what is my thought process
behind that code so i think that that
part can be achieved through commenting
you can definitely pull a piece of code
from stack overflow but your comments
will show
um
why you would why you are doing
something
so yeah
um
let's see i want to go over to one
anonymous question as well and make sure
i address some of those too um but
definitely leave your hands up as well
so i can come back over that way
but asama one of the
anonymous question was
i use r to query databases but i've
noticed sql is common in many industries
wondering what are your views on
learning sql
when i can do the same in r
um
very spoiled as as our users with
the ecosystem of packages that that can
make it
quite validating for you to sidestep
learning sql however i found it to be a
very useful skill
that that i personally should should
invest time in and and i think to
generalize that other people should too
uh just drawing on on my own experience
so i'm the sole data scientist with
three data engineers and they write
everything in in sql and so
you know to to better understand you
know their code and and how that
translates to
to the data that they're feeding me
um i think definitely having an
understanding just being able to to read
it is is helpful without you know
necessarily having to wait for them to
explain it to me
so i think
i think definitely investing in in sql
is is only a win for you um
personally
and it's it's good for your for your
resume as well to have that
it's a helpful point on working with
others too craig is exposing me right
now
[Laughter]
i did see that tweet
[Laughter]
um federica i see you had your hand
raised as well i'd love to have you ask
your question
uh hi
more than a question i was um i meant to
uh say something about this imposter
symptoms uh syndromes uh as i said um
my thoughts are
um like thinking about uh
being a student
and going to university and follow
different classes
so
you
might be able to be an expert and pass
your exam
because you stop everything and you
focus on the exam
and then you
um
uh you'll be able to
release all all your learning for for
that task for
um
passing the the assessment
but uh while you're learning and you're
following different classes you won't be
able to be an expert on all the
topics
so
while you're doing uh life coding and um
you know you present uh you post um
um
your resume for for a job and uh
you you might be uh
aware of different
you have of different things you have
uh
a different sort of skills uh soft
skills our skills but
uh when when someone calls you for for
for a job they may ask you something
that you are not doing um
very frequently
but you are a knowledge of
and
so the the time that it takes for you to
solve that task
is maybe a little bit longer
than what you are
then what it will usually takes
take if you if you are doing that task
every day as a routine
so when you work you do a routine you
you you are positioned in
inside a company doing something and
that that's something is a work so it's
repetitive
right you won't be able to span on
everything you have colleagues
you have experts to rely
uh
with and ask if you need help
so that the the difficulties is when you
do an interview
and
with the live coding you must be
you know sort of prepared for that task
because when you work you you do it
routinely
so that this is my
uh that was i was uh
thinking and i found quite difficult
sometimes to be able to do
um
everything very fast
so
[Music]
thank you
and thank you federica
eric i i see you had your hand raised
too
well first of all tan is way too kind
i'm not nearly as proficient at coding
in live streams as he is and he's
rescued me more than half the time on
debugging and all that but
i think the part i struggle with
especially as i start to get more
involved in my organization dns maybe
evaluate candidates coming in and things
like that is
finding like i'm not allowed to ask for
live coding like that's off the table
and the our process but
i've always struggled with finding ways
to assess how does somebody go about
solving a problem
and their techniques maybe not
necessarily getting the right answer but
what what investigational traits do they
have to solve things
everyone knows that's i've watched me
before i don't know the answer
everything i just have a few selected
sources i i look at and i try things out
and i make notes but trying to assess
that in these evaluations is just really
painful when you only have like 30
minutes to
45 minutes maybe with a candidate and
it's not so much a question just kind of
just
goes ranting about i wish there was a
better way to understand how people go
about solving problems and not be misled
by just looking at the end result of
like a github repo or a take-home exam
or whatnot but it's been healthy
discussion i've enjoyed listening
yeah definitely asthma do you have any
other thoughts on on that
um
i remember complaining to my organic
chemistry professor about his time tests
because there were so many questions it
was not feasible to get to all of them
and i just remember him asking like what
like what is the point of that really
like if i was let's say you know trying
to
trying to i guess like land uh
land a job as like a icu
like trauma person then it makes sense
to have these time tests in which you're
like very rigorously
evaluated on on the end product and if
you've you know caught on certain things
um in the assessment so i i think i
yeah i was like thinking about that as
as people were talking and i think we
just
i think for people that that that do
give these live coding
interviews i think just like really
really being thoughtful about what
you're trying to test and the end goal
here could make for more
holistic
interview process that that really gets
at what you're trying to um understand
about your candidate
yeah they they're awesome that was a
random example but no that's that's
extremely helpful yeah
i um
i saw there was an early a question
earlier um
for you about so it says in a healthcare
company how do you convince stakeholders
who are clinical experts
for example doctors to trust you and
your results as the data expert
yeah i think i've been super
uh fortunate in that regard there wasn't
much convincing that i needed to do
to convince the stakeholders of the
value of data maybe that's because we
are a digital first company
so you know yes we do have physical
clinics but but everything is is data
uh and so
you know because everything is is data
and if there is you know an
establishment of
of trust there in terms of you producing
uh quality work and and reliable
results then that that part is pretty
seamless i think in trying to convince
the stakeholders of the value
um there just isn't
um
there is no question as to like the the
value of the data because it's something
that the stakeholders need to look at
pretty much every day
for you know assessing
patients assessing processes
and identifying how those can can be
improved and optimized
maybe that has to do with the culture
so nick was on earlier in the call i
think he dropped off but
you know at every monthly team-wide
meeting and really every internal
meeting
you know he he asks for departments to
give an update and he
he puts into words a data driven update
so it's something from the get-go that
everyone is expected to
look at and to ask for and to interface
with me and my team uh to obtain those
insights so very grateful um to have
that that culture
and and for my job to be that much
easier in which i don't have to really
sell
people on on using
on using this stuff uh really the the
convincing is just in terms of you know
how the data should be best
displayed for them to then be able to
use it to make
decisions so we'll have conversations
about about that but
really it's it's been it's been almost
too easy
for us
in that regard
that's a great point about culture too
and i i'm thinking about people who are
looking for new jobs now i know we're
talking about like interviewing
techniques and maybe that's one way to
check for culture but what are some
other ways that you can get a better
feel for what that culture is going to
be like
before you start there
um
yeah i think you know maybe asking them
about
how
they think they would utilize
the the data science team how they're
currently utilizing the the data science
team
um and you know making sure that
that that data science team isn't just
you know off to the corner doing their
own thing but is fully integrated
uh within within the company uh so we
talked about like decentralized data
science teams versus centralized data
science teams so if it's decentralized
and you have you know a data scientist
into every department well then that's
that's kind of your answer right they've
invested in that
um
but i think you know in in certain
fields you um
just drawing from from what i know about
sports and my colleagues in in sports
you know many teams have invested in in
data scientists because you know teams
think that that gives them a competitive
advantage but
in terms of actually utilizing the
findings of that data science teams you
know that that's been uh lacking there's
many reasons for that and it's it's it's
certainly not the same reasons across
every team but
but it's it's it's it's fascinating to
to look into um and i think
um
uh some people have thrown around like
you know maybe we need decision
scientists on top of having a
data scientist or data science teams and
i think that's
that's a really interesting
conversation to have
is that something like a decision
scientist is that someone that you would
probably hire into
your organization
i think it would make sense yeah moving
forward i think right now at my company
we're really at the early stages of just
building that that infrastructure and
and and doing qa on that and at the same
time of course delivering um insights
and and value
but yeah i think i think as we mature
you know a decision scientist may make a
lot of sense you know um because they're
really the the expert in terms of taking
that data and then helping
helping to improve processes maybe
clinical
processes so i think that that would
make a ton of sense actually to to
invest in going forward i'm really
interested in actually in hearing if if
you are in a company that employs these
decision scientists or these
sort of operations engineers that make
use of of data specifically for process
improvement that's i would love to to
hear from you and what that looks like
i know frank your team had
changed the title to decision
intelligence
know if you have options if you have
things to weigh in on there
yeah so i'll just say that it also
blends into our conversation about data
scientists versus data analysts uh
the analysts that work on my team within
target within supply chain particularly
in transportation
we are interested like
we are a centralized team we sit with a
lot of other data analysts but my team
my analysts are so embedded with our
stakeholders and our users
they know the business almost just as
well as the business does and they know
how to manipulate data and model data
and pull data
just as well as any of the other
centralized teams
so
i use the term full stack data analyst
it is hard and it is rare and
maybe the learning process is is very
draining for some folks
but we get a ton of value um on both
sides of the table and having people who
are let's say
70 to 80 good at a lot of different
things
i have something to contribute here i
mean the term decision scientists have
heard of it
but
my challenge to that
need for such a position
um i challenge that notion um primarily
because if let's say you're presenting
an analysis and data science work to a
finance person or to a supply chain
functional person
they are the decision scientists here um
they are the ones to make a decision so
if you if there is a there's a data
scientist and then there is a decision
scientist
to the finance
leadership person who needs to make the
decision to define course of action for
an organization
whether the position is called decision
scientist or data scientist they are
still the outsider so the decision
makers already exist in organizations
they are the owner of owners of business
processes
and p ls and so forth
the
i think of it as we need to cultivate
the business owners to become better
decision makers with the data
that we provide them
i'll i'll make one last comment there so
it's a it's a great point right at the
end of the day that the analysts are not
the decision makers but the fact of the
matter is they become partners at the
table because they are able to really
understand the decision any decision
frameworks that are going to be put in
place in the iterations as well as say
hey that's great but the uncertainty in
the data
is this
and we right
we know that a lot of business users
want to use point estimates to make
their forecasts or the decisions
having having the trust built between
the the
data people right call them scientists
analysts whatever you want to uh and
then people making decisions so that the
data people have
a lot of weight and and input on the
decision i i found to be um it pays off
i see christy put a great comment into
the chat too that
i think it that all goes back to culture
too
mm-hmm
[Laughter]
um
yeah i mean it really does depend on um
not just like team culture uh for
example it sounds like frank has a
really great culture that he and his
team have created at target
um
you know the way that you uh represent
your team
by um you know
uh how you conduct interviews and things
like that that's that's kind of team
culture but then you have your company
culture
which is really a system of systems
right so you have
um a lot of different teams that are
producing and consuming data
and
you know i think that
some
some mechanisms of that workflow are not
going to work um you know across all all
organizations
another way of saying that is um you
know organizational structure plays a
really big point uh a really big
presence in and how
data science and data analytics get
um
consumed and communicated across an
organization or a company um you know a
lot of that has to do with staffing how
many data scientists there are um i
think you know i work in experimentation
i didn't actually introduce myself hi
i'm christy i work in experimentation at
grubhub
experimentation is a really great
example of of where
uh some of these these communication
type challenges come to a head because
experimentation sits at the intersection
of finance and product and marketing and
engineering and data science and
analytics and so we all have to really
think hard about how to work together um
and it's it's not easy and i'll also say
you know i don't think a lot of even
even top-tier organizations have this
problem fully fleshed out and solved um
you know for for a lot of the the newer
uh data scientists on the call i think
it's really important as you take on
your new career as a data scientist
to just kind of um
keep in your back pocket data science is
still really really new uh relative to
software development um
developers have uh put into place
all kinds of processes and workflows
over the years to uh operationalize
their work very efficiently and i think
that that's still kind of a source of
frustration for a lot of data scientists
in industry um so you know as you as you
take on your new job
exercise a little bit of patience um
remember that uh
you know
not all of this stuff is really fleshed
out yet and you can be a source of
inspiration for um solving some of these
problems i know that that's something
that's really
driven me as as i became a data
scientist just five five or six years
ago
is i'm super passionate about how do we
operationalize data science effectively
because i would say that most companies
are probably getting about 60 of their
roi
on the data scientists they hire we can
do so much more
um
than than we're i think able to do today
we just need
the tools and the leadership and the um
i think just the experience even we have
to fail to learn and so like how do we
figure out how to move these things
forward it's a big space but um i think
you know the maturity is coming we just
we need more people like you
[Laughter]
we're just saying we need to save that
little snippet too that's super helpful
um
asthma i
i know i just message you to make sure
it's okay to stay on a few more minutes
because there's so many other great
questions too and i feel like an hour
just went by
so quickly um
but craig i see you had a great question
around remote work do you want to ask
that one
sure
um yeah so i work for a consulting firm
and the client is all
on premises
and you know i've been
hired to work remotely
so yeah i just wanted to see if anybody
wanted to talk about
how hiring remotely has gone and whether
or not you see that
remaining in the field or if you if
there's some chance that we're going to
be going back to more in-person type
situations because i don't think a
hybrid environment works from a
an advancement a career advancement
perspective i see obviously you're
at
work um but i don't know if your
colleagues are or not so
if anybody wants to talk about that more
feel free
yeah
i think
you know i
very fortunate once again that that
pursue care
was created
with
the intention of having a significant
portion of its workforce be
fully
remote and so i think
right off the bat the culture and the
tools we've adopted and the processes
we've adopted
were
friendly to that to having the workforce
be remote
i think there's a lot of interesting
debate about
sort of career advancement for people
that are remote versus in person
that people that are remote may miss out
on
promotions or not be considered uh
for for those i think that's that's a
valid conversation to have
with your managers or just be mindful of
that if that's if that's your goal
within the company
i think you know there's pros and cons
to being remote for myself you know do i
wish i had more face time
uh with with other stakeholders sort of
in person you know grabbing lunch or or
doing all that but i mean the pandemic
is a thing so that's not i mean if if
the pandemic was over let's say then
then yeah i wish i would have more
more of those organic
experiences for for bonding and and all
of that but
um
i think i think being remote has has
paid dividends in terms of my
productivity and my overall happiness
and my ability to to kind of structure
my day i i know that personally i don't
really like to work in mornings my
productivity kind of starts at like 11
a.m until 3 p.m and then i have to go
make lunch and eat and then i like to
kind of get back into it in the evening
sometimes so that flexibility has been
has been really great um
for me personally but i i think it does
come with some
drawbacks that that i think people
should be
mindful of
does it does anyone else have any other
thoughts here too or want to jump in i
don't want to
switch the topic too quickly
you can go first
um
so i've had my last couple jobs now
remote
and
it didn't
all my customers that i served were
scattered all over the united states
so there was no possible way that i was
going to get face time face time with
him you know i sat in boston with my
customers st louis in california and
chicago
whatever else i could have been on the
moon and it wouldn't matter um
my wife works for one of the largest
companies here
and
same same issue she has people all over
the globe that she works with on the
team
there's no way you're going to get the
facetime and if you're requiring the
facetime for people to
um advance
then that means you don't value the work
the work should speak for itself
and if it doesn't
then i think it's a corporate culture
you're not valuing it or not
um and so because most of the stuff can
be done remotely it's not physically
possible to
be in the office with everybody you need
to work with just it's just not possible
um especially with these globalized
organizations
um
and and esme's point
it gives people the flexibility you know
at the end of the day is
i only care if you get the job done
okay if it takes an hour
30 minutes or 12 hours
you know you we all know the schedule we
make it realistic
and that's it it's hit the deadlines um
i worked remotely for a european company
and all they told me was
you need to get these amount of
documents in by x time on friday
um
and that's it
and you know some days i would be
scrambling late thursday night because
it wasn't going that well uh and then
one time i delivered something early and
the rating agency was in their office
and they were like hey ray agency was
asking all about the document they said
yeah we just got in this is an example
of it the rating agency was great you
get a you get an a in that department um
so it was pretty clear just make this
deadline um
but that's my two cents on that
right for sure yeah um i just i couldn't
imagine kind of sitting at an office
from nine to five
um it's just it doesn't really drive
with with how most people uh work
um one thing though that i that i think
about um
i i saw this on twitter someone saying
you know junior
software engineers because of this shift
to remote work
will have their learning stunted or or
something like that because they just
don't have that
that much face time with more senior
software engineers in which they can
kind of just like pop into their office
and like ask questions or or see how
it's resolved and that's something that
i think about maybe when i when i will
hire you know more junior data
scientists right out of school
um
i think
yeah i i think as long as there's
structure in place to make sure that
that there's enough sort of one-on-one
time and mentorship time that we can
sidestep that but that's that's
something i'm i think about as well with
with the shift to remote work i know
that that was really valuable for me
when i was a data analyst
at massachusetts gen i would just like
constantly pop into my more senior
people and ask them to to help me out
and
i think it's just more awkward to do it
with
well maybe not more awkward but on slack
you just like hey like i'm stuck can you
get on zoom with me or something but
it's just a little i guess a little more
awkward to do it that way
versus just like barging into
your co-worker's office but yeah
yeah
i know some people have talked about
like having office hours too i wonder if
like having
virtual office hours
helps with that
yeah definitely
zach i see you had your hand raised
yeah so i was just going to the point no
i think as may
said a lot about it
me being junior at the moment
so i'm on a bit of a different thing i'm
on the training and
so i went into the job with my skills
and then they teach you some skills even
then i'm the only person in my team
i think
so if i have a problem with something i
have to giggle it or
look at like they it's mainly excel or
microsoft power bi
um so like
uh i'm not sure if tam's still there or
not but like for personal projects i
talked to tan quite a lot
uh and he answers like he's that person
basically that i go to
uh if i have any questions so yeah i
think
whoa
i think i would benefit from going the
office and
just haven't where it's less awkward i'm
not like sending a message to someone
so it's also one of these things where
you can you can have those like two
minute quick conversations you can't
really have a hey
could
foreign
going for a meeting and it's it's that
thing that i think like that time in
where
i think it's actually critical that a
lot of people don't realize
is the end of meeting getting to next
meeting
those five minutes so you can answer a
lot of questions for the junior person
uh well you don't get that in
zoom or teams or whatever platform
you're using
yeah
that like walking in the hallway with
people in time
mark i i see you had a great question
you just asked now on
professional development would you want
to jump in and add some context to that
one
yeah sure and i guess it was part of a
question
and part of a statement that i think
it's it's good to have this sort of
scheduled time but i asked um if anyone
else has
um you know scheduled time
um to work on non-work projects um i saw
brian responded
um that he designated some portion of
fridays to uh
for you know folks on his team to work
on
uh developing technical skills and um i
know that something
i guess again a statement that i found
to be helpful is that i have that same
sort of time that i've gotten
you know my managers sign on for like
working on non-work projects that i find
interesting to help develop skills that
i otherwise wouldn't necessarily
encounter in day-to-day work um
so
i find it useful i just i didn't know if
anyone else had any thoughts on you know
that sort of uh
thing in the workday and i know also you
know there's sometimes people suggest
here
oh you should code like all the time
outside of work but i know some people
don't like to you know they want to have
a clean separation between
um you know the work day and then like
free time on afternoons and the weekends
and that's a good way to still get in
you know personal practice without you
know having to sacrifice
free time
yeah that's a that's a great question
and i rachel's comments
is perfect um they said we're told feel
free to take time for professional
development but it's implied that is
when your work is finished and it never
that's perfect um i think i'll i'll i'll
add that once again culture is important
and i'm not just saying that as a as a
throwaway so
nick my ceo evaluates
his staff based on what's called smart
goals i can't recall for the life of me
what that acronym is but
smart goals is things that you've you
know achieved over the the course of one
year and
one of those smart goals has to be the
demonstration of your professional
development
and that could look
differently for for for people and so
you know having
yes exactly specific measurable
achievable relevant and time-bound um
and and and because of that because it's
literally part of my smart goals and
that that justifies you know time that i
set aside for for my professional
development and um
yeah and it doesn't it doesn't have to
be you know sort of coding
professional development could be
literally reading i don't know
papers on uh
plant science like i
often times inspiration
and the learning of new techniques and
new frameworks could come from fields
that that
could look very different
from the field that you're working in
currently
so i think i think having sort of
leadership that that understands that
and that accommodates that and that
embeds embeds it in your performance is
is is really great
and so with that i
i told nick i wanted to
ta a data science class fridays from 10
to 1 pm and you know i didn't really
need to convince him of that he's like
okay yeah that makes sense because
you're going to learn from your students
and
and it's you're going to learn you know
about how to communicate you know things
to to to people that don't have
experience with doing that and that's a
that's a that's a big skill to have
because you'll be i think as a data
scientist often interfacing with people
that that um don't understand it and
that you will need to explain it
so yeah
i love that you're taling that class too
that's awesome
um i
i want to try and get to everyone's
questions too but i know some people had
to drop so if you're on and there's a
question that we didn't get to yet feel
free to raise your hand and ask that
live too
one of the the questions from earlier
asthma was
i know we talked about how you have
three data engineers and then
data scientists and if
that's all under your team as well
like do you manage the data engineering
side
um
and the question was is your area of
expertise also in data engineering if
not how do you go about managing that
role
right it's it's it's definitely not a
part of my skill set but i'm learning
you know
slowly but surely through through them
you know good practices and and so forth
so
i think i'm like a pseudo really pseudo
data architect in in that way um so you
know i sort of
uh
interface with the vendors in terms of
negotiating you know data access and how
to obtain that data and then i go back
to my data engineers and tell them okay
this is what the data looks like this is
you know the cleaning that needs to be
done this is how we should format it
such that it makes it easier to you know
slice and dice the data whenever we need
to
um and so that's that's how i've managed
this team is sort of you know give them
an understanding of the business which
then informs how the data should should
ideally
be structured to meet those
those business needs
um
but yeah i i certainly don't don't
really have intimate experience of of
data engineering i have some ideas
but but it's definitely them almost
managing me in a sense um so it's a good
good two-way
two-way street there
definitely
i see one other question from yuri that
we didn't ask and i know we're quite
over so we'll start to wrap up in in a
few minutes here but
um the question was how much of data
science is data exploration versus
machine learning first deep learning
yeah
so
i really think it depends on on the
company and the
the team and and so forth i can tell you
pursue care machine learning right now
occupy zero of our time just because
we're just literally not there yet
um
but it's something that you know once
our data warehouse is mature and and
we've understood the basics about our
business then for sure that will become
a big a bigger part of our time
can i uh can i elaborate on the question
yes definitely sorry i didn't know you
were still there
yeah um
so
when i i tried to learn this material
and i feel before going into machine
learning which feels much
more complex i try to
do the data science part without it so i
wonder how you
how you study these
layers of complications
am i clear
um i i think so uh
you know i think
i think having exposure to machine
learning is important especially if you
can fit it into your day because there
will be a time in which you're you're
you're probably going to have a question
that involves you you know modeling and
maybe drawing
from a machine learning model but
um yeah i think it's kind of the things
like learn to what's the expression
learn to walk before you run type of
thing i think getting really good at
using group by and summarize will
will make will make your
uh stakeholder is very
very happy uh so
i i think if i were to give advice on on
someone kind of
starting out i'd focus on on getting
really good at
you know being able to slice and dice
the data and represent it in efficient
ways before you know
moving on to
more fancier and more complex uh
questions
thank you
yeah
thank you all so much for joining and
staying on
past the hour too i i really appreciate
you jumping on here asthma and sharing
all your insights and experience with us
too
what's the best way for people to get in
contact with you if they had follow-up
questions god this was so fun i could
literally do this for hours um but we
all have jobs to go to um yeah i think
the best way is is twitter uh
i'm usually very active on there and and
will definitely respond so
thanks i i'm known as jeep wrangler
owner um it's yes it is my account
ask with tweets about all things data
science jeeps cats snowboarding i've
noticed right yeah
i forgot we were gonna do this from a
brewery as well that was the goal
oh yeah
oh but omicron yeah one of these days
we'll all be in person sure
thank you so much and thank you all for
joining
have a great rest of the day
it